Come on,
you mentioned to me this is the sacred
lake.
This is my spot for me to read.
Can't tell you the number of books have
right here.
Hm.
Oh my God.
It's freezing.
Absolutely.
With a couple of children.
I think it would pull it out and
everything.
I know myself and we've been good.
We haven't done anything to be ashamed
of and it's a good thing.
I want to be good.
Okay.
It would be pretty cool to design a film
studies course around,
call me by your name.
The movie opens up its own interesting
lane in film history,
populated by auteurs trying to disappear
from their work,
which is a paradox worth exploring.
The movies that this class would
feature.
A handful of which you just saw in the
opening sequence,
have similarities that are focused by
call me by your name and by director
Luca Quad Nino's vision.
It's not that quite an Nino quotes or
pays homage to his influences.
He does something that's much harder.
He actually learns the lessons that
these influences teach and applies them
in a way that adds to his personal
style.
The most obvious influence I think are
the films of James Ivory specifically to
have his elm forester adaptations,
a room with a view,
and Morris I say obvious because ivory
was in his late eighties.
No less the screenwriter for call me by
your name.
The market has a long career at the
merchant ivory production company is all
over this movie now you might not know
merchant tie for you.
The director,
producer,
team of ivory and his life partner is
mile merchant,
but along with their screenwriter,
ruth,
Joe Vala,
they created 44 films together,
fun,
highbrow,
literary adaptations,
period pieces with lavish costumes and
sets,
and this may sound like stuffy pump is
filmmaking,
but the merchant ivory films or anything
but they leave with life room with a
view.
For example,
nature is a symbol of freedom against
the social restrictions of the Gordian
England ivory,
like Wat a Nino captures the warm
tactile qualities of being outdoors and
uses the sense memory that these images
and sounds evoke as a way to trigger
empathy for the characters
in both films.
The desire for summer afternoons is
paralleled with the desire for love or
sex
in Morris and adaptation of foresters,
novel of homosexual love.
The similarities are more apparent,
the important ways that both Morris and
Leo tentatively realized and act upon
their feelings are physical,
not verbal,
and this is what a good filmmaker and
good actors bring to an adaptation.
The translation dialogue into gesture.
Sure.
A second key influence are the films of
Eric Rohmer,
the last of the French new wave
directors who style was less
iconoclastic than Godard or truffaut,
yet whose career sustained in quality
much longer than many of his
contemporaries.
Romero is known as a very wordy
filmmaker.
His movies feature characters having
extended philosophical conversations on
love and desire.
Yet what Gwadar Nino draws from him is
his simplicity,
his unsentimental presentation of
characters in space and his camera work
like the genre Anwar,
who came before him.
Romana is interested in realism,
but not at the expense of beauty like
roamers and renoirs squat.
A Nino's camera in call me by your name
isn't showy and his editing isn't
manipulative.
Quad Nino and a cinematographer only
used one lens,
a 35 millimeter to mimic roughly the
feel of human eyesight and the camera
follows the action,
but in the way and observer might in all
of these filmmakers,
long takes,
don't feel stylized or distracting.
They function as a window into the
environment and it's important that we
see that environment.
This space is these characters inhabit,
so depth of field is usually deep and
the use of closeups is rare.
As Ramiro once said,
the reason I don't like a close up is
because it excludes,
it doesn't add,
it takes away.
It suppresses the relationship of the
character to the set,
and what's important for Guantanamo,
Nino is that he gives the actors enough
room and time for the space between them
to become charged with emotion.
Finally,
maybe the most important influence on
the structure of call me by your name is
the French director.
Maurice Plr,
especially his film I s'mores law is
another figure on the outer rim of the
French new wave who barely has any
recognition in America.
His films are rough and unsentimental to
the extreme,
even sloppy at times,
but the brim with a wild energy,
they're driven by people who are slaves
to impulse and what Quad Nino admires
about plr is how these impulses drive
the construction of the narrative.
It's almost dizzying how a no s'mores,
for example,
a coming of age film about a sexually
charged adolescent trips from scene to
scene without consideration for a
traditional story arc that cut between
two shots could represent a jump of two
seconds or two months and the audience
isn't prepare for either when to call me
by your name isn't as extreme as this,
but gotten dino's narrative follows a
similar rhythm where the through line
isn't the developments of a three act
plot,
but rather the energy of Elios desire
and how that manifests.
These unusual structures are so
important because narrative art is one
of the ways in which we model our own
lives and there can be falseness in what
is sometimes called Hollywood films that
influences our expectations of
experience.
For instance,
the whole time I was watching call me by
your name.
I was anxious for the person or the
institution that would inevitably
challenge Elio and Oliver is affair.
It's something I'd come to expect in
films and stories of this kind,
but when that didn't happen and I
released that pent up energy,
it was a revolutionary feeling like the
film was opening up a new corner of life
differently to see things,
see without my eyes first time that you
don't have to understand these films or
these directors to enjoy.
Call me by your name.
In fact,
this lineage is built around the notion
that you can have a radical effect on
viewers without a radical style.
I think why Denino's sin,
Ophelia?
His love of films is the very best kind.
It doesn't exclude people for not being
in the know.
It brings influences together in the
service of a brand new style to
appreciate it.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes that process of building your
website really simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thank you guys again,
and I'll see you next week for a new
video.